A few interesting.
Uh, it's interesting how the dynamics on the
David Pakman show sub Reddit have sort of
been shifting over the last few months.
We have more moderators.
I think the sub Reddit is now over 16,000,
uh, of our viewers and listeners participating.
But the tone and tenor has changed in a lot
of ways and it seems to be getting more pragmatic
in some sense.
A few interesting posts I found this morning,
uh, at David pakman.com/reddit that I want
to point out to you.
One is from a user named, Hey, they're 91
who says, will you vote for Joe Biden if he
is the nominee?
Um, presumably this is a question for democratic
party voters who may be supporting someone
other than Joe Biden in the primary, in their
state.
And, uh, I, my instinct and I actually want
to hear from the audience about this, my instinct
is that most democratic primary voters understand
that if you fell for the idea in 2016, that
if it's not Bernie, who cares if it's Hillary
or, or, or, or Trump.
That was a disastrous point of view.
And now that we see the effect that Donald
Trump has, uh, has had and will have on geopolitical
alliances long after he's out of the white
house, when we see the number of judges, not
just to the Supreme court, but importantly
to lower courts, uh, and how Donald Trump
will have a multigenerational impact as a
result of that.
I hope anybody who thought Hillary or Trump,
it's sort of the same if it's not Bernie.
I hope you've all been dizzy disabused of
that notion over the last few years.
I know, I certainly have, I am not going to
be voting for Joe Biden in the democratic
primary.
I know that Joe Biden recently said he would
consider a Republican as a running mate.
That's bonkers to me at this point in time.
Um, but if it's Biden versus Trump, I'm going
to vote for Biden.
The judges that Joe Biden would select would
be a far cry from those that Donald Trump
has selected.
The way Joe Biden would be respected around
the world, even if it's not what I would like.
It's not the ideal.
It's night and day compared to Donald Trump.
So if Biden is the nominee, I will be supporting
him over Donald Trump.
I want to hear from you where, where is your
head?
Uh, on this another post, uh, by a user named
posse Comitatus who said, Andrew Yang's suppose
it's support for Medicare for all has become
more dubious after his more detailed proposal
has come out.
I read quite a bit about this, um, uh, over
the last 24 hours and I am struggling with
Andrew Yang's position on healthcare.
Now, as many of you know, Andrew Yang granted
me, it's either two or three interviews.
He's been on the program since he's gotten
bigger and more well known.
They've just been ignoring our requests for
an interview.
I want Andrew Yang to come back on the program.
So we could talk about this.
I have questions about his healthcare plan.
He had said he has used the term Medicare
for all, but also put out a plan that does
not describe anything approaching Medicare
for all.
I want him back on the program.
I would like him back on the program to talk
about his VAT tax and the way that it would,
uh, specifically be targeted, targeted so-called
luxury goods, uh, to not be a regressive tax.
I have a lot of things I want to talk to him
about.
I understand a lot of people want him back
on the show.
They are ignoring us and listen, I understand
he's getting on the Ellen show now.
We are small potatoes compared to that.
Um, but I think there would be value in him
coming back on and answering these questions.
So if you want to respectfully ask him and
his staffers to get them back on the show,
he's welcome.
Anytime I have questions about the health
care plan and many other things I would love
to discuss with Andrew Yang.
Uh, lastly, a user named nug Wrangler posted
to the subreddit debate was David Abata during
the elevator incident.
So on the bonus show on Monday, I told a story
of something that happened in an elevator
at Paris, Charlotte Charles de Gaulle airport
on Sunday when I was flying back from Paris.
And this has created a rift in the David Pakman
show community.
Was I an alpha Chad VI by virtue of how I
handled the situation or was I a beta?
And nug Wrangler says, I contend that David
did not tuck and run a beta would have actually
stayed.
I argue that David acted like a Chad strutting
through the elevator, the full elevator, all
the way from the back whilst being weighed
down by pounds of luggage.
I believe my behavior in the Charles de Gaulle
airport elevator, it was alpha.
I do.
And if this is at all interesting to you,
become a member and then listen to the December
30th bonus show and judge for yourself.
Join the discussion is more than 16,000 of
our viewers and listeners already have at
the David Pakman show subreddit.
Find it at David pakman.com/reddit